l'espace et je suis pas pour un truc est
là pour bien quoi t'est-ce tiens qu'est
ce qu'il a vu à quoi ou qu'est ce qu'il
ya
mon souhait c'est bon tu arrives là une
sorte tout le monde qu'est ce qui vous
arrive sur vous est fourni alors gérard
michel les côtes d'armor chantait
interquartiers de pétanque en travel mi
2017 et 17 août et regardez moi bien
dans les yeux je regarde quand vais je
regarde dans les yeux moi je suis là
pour dire des vérités d'accord d'ici là
le fonds présente et chants danses et en
dallaire est là depuis vingt ans mais en
hiver la de tous consensus audiovisuelle
vous êtes tous dans nos petits ronds de
cuir est il plus simple vérité
d'accord je suis à pour des tva qu'elle
avait arrêté kg est à dire la vérité tu
laisses deux roues se télécharge l'idée
dans la tête
d'accord c'est quoi la vérité toile a
été acceptée lyreco de caméras mais je
te préviens si tu coupes parce qu'on l'a
en direct je veux manger une soupe de
parole dans la gueule c'est avec dit
fait d'accord alors c'est quoi la haye
j'ai appris qu'il y avait un consensus
gouvernementale d'accord avec l'appui
général de la télévision et du paf on va
supprimer nos monuments d'accord nos
institutions patrick sébastien au départ
est atteint c'est un truc c'est qu'on a
viré il n'y a personne ici autour de la
table pour soutenir les copains troquet
il ya des jeunes hôtels aloft qui
connaissent pas pratiquants laisse
pantois mais les violets ont soutien au
sultan pas les collègues on se tait by
collègue jean richard
mais sa voix plaignent en effet
aujourd'hui je reconnais que les coups
et des violences étaient sept à ses
repères nikos est permis corrective de
sérieux petit monde qui débutent en a
ici
c'est une collègue de drive in a high
kicks et tourner les serviettes mois le
samedi soir à salou le batteur michel
aurait pompe à l'été suite répondu il
sait rien et l'ex apprend quoi comme
quoi qu'en 2021
ouais il allait nous submerger alors là
moi série coûtent cher tout partait quoi
c'est quoi et par terre jean pierre
pernaut a annoncé ce qu on perd nous
chassaient de ces maisons pichat passé
nous avions vu j'ai plus d'un sur jean
pierre barrau attends je suis frais j'ai
fait le vaccin ce matin s'amuse écoles
la moustache et le jour aujourd'hui en
héros qui ont un message à ton de
secondes bientôt texte [ __ ] de
willisau lu ils ont bien fait en louche
alors moi est bon que tu l'aies cyril
parce que c'est un ami du peuple
on sait qu'à l'habitude peuple et je
sais que le peuple ne laissera pas ta
samatan c'est fragile ces séries alors
oui je vois toi je sais que laissera pas
tomber la peur alors je lui te proposait
d'accord chacun regarde moi je te
regarde tu à produire une émission ou
encore qu'il va passer tous les jours le
samedi soir ouais d'accord ça plaît le
plus grand cabaret du trader j'aurais
parlé à l'amicale laïque de veto ils
étaient comme des draps ça va cartonner
ah ben c'est simple ils étaient ravis
comme castaldi après une campagne déjà
qu'ils étaient au top
d'accord et ce qui va se passer le
concept qu'il est très simple c'est
toujours la luttre ailleurs avec des
tours de magie avec un contorsionniste
na qui crachent du feu et abroge les
couilles ben ça c'est fait donc en
attendant tu me diras ce que tu en
penses
en attendant côté dans le gouvernorat
que tu fais de la télé maintenant
d'accord tu peux me dire où on en est là
confiné les confiner recompilé atouts
résident et s'est lancé dans son système
ce n'est plus moi je sais plus quoi
faire dans les mers tu te dis j'en ai
marre en tout cas le ton dans l'
ouverture la culture c'est-à-dire bar
bistro muette excellent terreau à aix et
terra j'ai créé pour l'application ou ne
nous lâche pas dit c'est quoi ces sabots
l'insta 3 g
asta 3 g bon c'est pour faire les ja
poireau entre amis entre collègues de
bureau pour ceux qui sont l'ancienne
école
ceux qui sont l'ancienne école bomba
était tel numéro de téléphone claudio
répondent tous les jours n'importe
quelle heure de la nuit ou de jour donc
geros est d'accord 61 71 47 56 qu'est ce
que la sépaq à merci toute la droite
inquiète pas c'est rien c'est qui m'a
répondu tu as fait le malin c'est qui
mais elle inquiète assyriens syriens
tombèrent de baleines t'emmerde pas
qu'on regarde pas merci benjamin
castaldi
[Applaudissements]